[Música]
porque en colombia fue capturado el
hombre más buscado del país alias
otoniel considerado el máximo jefe de la
organización criminal el clan del golfo
dedicada al tráfico de drogas
dairo antonio úsuga será extraditado a
estados unidos donde es acusado de
importar al menos 73 toneladas métricas
de cocaína entre los años 2003 y 2014
las autoridades estadounidenses habían
ofrecido una recompensa de 5 millones de
dólares por información que condujera a
su captura
otoniel fue trasladado a una base
militar en la ciudad de bogotá la
capital de colombia desde donde se va a
gestionar su extradición hasta eeuu ya
para ello está conmigo en el estudio en
esto rosanía director ejecutivo del
centro de estudios en seguridad y paz en
colombia' a néstor gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 la importancia y otoniel
además el presidente iván duque lo llegó
a comparar con pablo escobar era tan
importante tan grande este digamos al
narcotraficante entre otros delitos que
cometía alias otoniel es un
narcotraficante muy importante pero no
llega a la dimensión escobar porque el
narcotráfico es un eslabón que es una
cadena que tiene seis eslabones es el
cultivo el laboratorio el tráfico
propiamente de la cocaína la
comercialización en calle el consumo y
el lavado de activos esos seis elementos
componen el narcotráfico hoy colombia
que tiene sólo tiene el tema del cultivo
el procesamiento de la droga y hasta ahí
porque hoy los principales
transportistas los transportadores son
los mexicanos entonces compararlo con
pablo escobar no tiene un diámetro
porque porque pablo es cual si tenía los
seis eslabones pablo escobar tenía desde
el cultivo hasta vender la cocaína en
las calles de eeuu europa y otro no
tenían simplemente se dedica es el tema
de manejar cultivos procesamiento y
venderse a los mexicanos y por eso la
importancia cierto de alegato niell
entre entre otras entre otras cosas que
manejaba cual otros delitos manejaba
otoniel aquí en colombia pues no tiene
implicaciones que con violaciones a los
derechos humanos desplazamiento forzado
reclutamiento de menores temas de abuso
sexual en sus filas y digamos tener el
control de minería ilegal y tráfico
ilegal de combustibles pero él centro de
toda esta operación criminal era el tema
del narcotráfico ahora néstor ya pues
digamos capturaron a otoniel van a hacer
la extradición efectiva a eeuu todavía
no se sabe en qué plazos lo van a hacer
pero qué va a pasar con el clan del
golfo porque vulnera una decisión
criminal tan grande pues evidentemente
con la caída de otoniel no se va a
acabar porque pues el digamos otoniel es
el segundo al mando de esta organización
cierto néstor era el primero pero la
característica del clan del golfo es que
es una organización descentralizada es
muy diferentes por ejemplo a las farc
que era una organización piramidal
jerárquica que tenía un jefe aquí
funcionan más por franquicias entonces
lo que tenemos son diferentes pequeños
núcleos a nivel nacional que utilizan el
nombre clan del golfo pero que no
recibían directamente órdenes de otoniel
entonces la operación va a seguir
completamente normal porque el dinero
que se mueve aquí es muy importante y
sólo una cifra un kilo de cocaína en
colombia hoy está fluctuando puesto en
la puerta de un laboratorio están
fluctuando más o menos entre dos mil dos
mil quinientos dólares ese mismo kilo de
cocaína puesto en las calles de miami
están entre 30 y 35 mil dólares en nueva
york en 45 mil dólares y en las calles
de toque un kilo de cocaína colombiano
puesta por encima de 100 mil dólares a
esos precios el negocio no se va a
detener con una característica por donde
capturaron auto nivel está la salida al
pacífico cercana y por ahí salen más o
menos los semisumergibles que cada uno
lleva diez mil kilos de cocaína y todos
los días están saliendo con ese negocio
tan grande que obteniendo éste no va a
implicar en la eso le quería decir
cuáles son los puertos son más
importantes en colombia por dónde sale
este tráfico este tráfico de drogas y si
además pues el gobierno colombiano está
haciendo algo ya para pues poder
controlarlo y qué está pasando también
con los cultivos ilícitos de cocaína
cuatro grandes rutas colombia tiene la
más grande la costa pacífica nariñense
caucana en la frontera con el ecuador
ahí sale el 70% de la cocaína vía mar y
esa hace lo que se llama largo el
pacifico bajan hasta de las islas
galápagos llegan a méxico méxico eeuu la
segunda gran salida lo que es la ruta
del caribe que sacan la droga hacia
venezuela y por vía aérea sale la
república dominicana haití méxico y
méxico eeuu la tercera por brasil que
hay un mar muy grande sale hacia manaos
de ahí compra compran los brasileros y
la transportan finalmente a áfrica
áfrica asia mediterráneo y europa y la
última es la de centroamérica que es la
que manejaba directamente otoniel que es
por la frontera con panamá ahora néstor
también acaba llegar a una información
digamos pues de último momento si se
quiere porque tres soldados son muertos
dejó un ataque con explosivos
perpetrados el pasado lunes en una zona
en turbo antioquia por el clan del golfo
no informaron esto las autoridades y se
puede decir que esto es como es
represalia por la captura de alias
otoniel podemos ver entonces ya una gran
represalia digamos al gobierno al
ejército colombiano por la captura de
otoniel pues la con delincuentes nunca
se sabe y no hay nada seguro pero lo que
es cierto es que estos nuevos grupos ya
no están en la lógica de una
confrontación ni una guerra contra el
estado lo más importante para ellos es
el negocio y que el negocio no se vea
afectado un ejemplo rápido cuando guacho
del frente de oliver sinisterra captura
y asesina a dos periodistas ecuatorianos
al molestos con él eran los carteles
mexicanos porque lo que hizo fue traer
toda la atención de la comunidad
internacional y separó la producción de
cocaína en el sur del país entonces ya
los nuevos grupos no se van a una
confrontación con el estado porque
tienen que sostener la cadena logística
de las rutas del narcotráfico sin que se
vayan a ver afectadas qué tan importante
va a ser el testimonio si lo llega a dar
de otoniel en estados unidos con su
extradición para poder darle golpes a
esta estructura criminal tan grande como
es el clan del golfo eeuu mire con
cuánto va a rebajar la pena con dos
variables nombres y número de rutas a
más nombres llamar rutas va a bajar la
pena por eso también
otoniel tiene un enemigo muy grande que
son sus antiguos socios ellos están muy
preocupados de que otro día llega eeuu y
van a hacer van a estar muy interesados
en asesinarlo antes de que se extradita
digamos ahorita autoridades se encuentra
en una base militar pero es posible que
se pueda presentar algún tipo de
percance
de aquí a su extradición a eeuu con lo
que acaba de decir las amenazas que
tienen por supuesto porque no les
interesa estos grupos criminales que
otoniel puede hablar con justicia
estadounidense va a ser el hombre más
justo colombia porque el gobierno
colombiano y el gobierno americano están
muy atentos a todo lo que va a los
nombres que tienen que empezar a decir y
las rutas que empieza a declarar
entonces va a ser el más custodiado
porque sabe que no sólo es que lo vayan
a matar y es que lo pueden envenenar le
puede pasar algo dentro de una cárcel
entonces por eso está dentro de una
unidad militar y va a saber el nombre
más custodiado de este país ahora
hablemos de las disidencias de las farc
y ln ellos si cooperan y trabajan
digamos en conjunto con el clan del
golfo con lo que esto usted estaba
diciendo también antes no tiene dígame
no tiene una cooperación directa en el
sentido de que hagan negocios juntos
pero se respetan las rutas que eso es
diferente a lo que sucedía en el pasado
hoy cada uno tiene unas rutas y unos
caminos unos negocios y unos clientes y
nos están digamos no les interesa llegar
a una confrontación en algún momento si
ve en la historia del país vivimos una
guerra muy dura entre las farc y el ln
por el control de rutas eso ya no se ha
vuelto a ver porque hoy la lógica es que
cada negocio y cada grupo está muy
concentrado en sostener su negocio
criminal